dirigez direction est bien le plateau en
pour découvrir le plateau du débat et
puis ensuite direction à sa loge un
quart d'heure plus tard c'était au tour
du président candidat emmanuel macron
d'arrivée à l'entrée de ce studio il est
accompagné de son épouse brigitte macro
et emmanuel macron il a pris un petit
bain poulain il a pris le temps de
serrer la main ou dizaine deux personnes
qui étaient présentes pour l'accueillir
voilà c'était un style différent assez
décontracté d'ailleurs on lui a posé la
question de savoir comment il se sentait
écouter
concentré prêt pour un débat qui doit
nous permettre à l'un l'autre de
d'expliquer nos idées nos projets pour
la france de clarifier aussi tout ce qui
doit l'être de part et d'autre
[Musique]